so this is a Tiger millionaire uh sorry
it took so long to get these like I said
just getting over his sickness and do a
pop quiz hotshot and stuff like that
kinetics and everything said sorry no
years at York he's a jerk
I love Tiger millionaire no he's a jerk
here uh I've never seen a plant turn
against his man I love that announcer uh
that guy was right the funniest thing uh
so this is an episode where um Anna's an
effete and look I'm in the shadows who
are you I am Robert Oh
I'm Batman well what's the other purple
one I could never get that name down
amethyst amethyst amethyst who are you
oh my god if you have a fifth collected
rocks that's a child uh so she doesn't
like being told what to do so she sneaks
out mill the night and does wrestling as
a dude Stephen finds out is just like
hey I want to join too so he becomes
Tiger millionaire with this kooky
backstory and garnet and pearl find out
and they're like hey stop but it turns
out surprise Lucy knows snowflake
obsidian
I'm only saying you got these three
girls they need like a fourth wonder
they need a Winston that should be
snowflake well I guess garnets already
black so but maybe some other ethnicity
anyway keep going I was pretty much done
and you left it where I had nowhere else
to go now we just talked about that
crippling racist remark and ever move
you from all history like they did with
Hulk Hogan you bastard I well that ties
into the whole verse exactly so much
Isis
they need a win to loan she's blacks
obviously that's that counts that's just
the wins because that's all he was he
was just the black Oh in that movie yeah
they it was supposed to be a bigger role
I think meant for any money so let's be
honest yes now Bernie Hudson who is the
man he's totally made the most out of
that role but yeah I think even he would
tell you yeah I was an afterthought and
that I was my black dude very much all I
am yeah hold we made the best of that so
uh but anywho we're talking about them
going to wrestling you know I often
forget cuz we've been away from it for a
while Michael yeah these are really
shorted over pretty quick so it's like
after they're done if I could you always
let your talk about wrestling for a sec
yeah I don't know we're the ones to talk
about this because I think the last time
we watch wrestling
we were watching Hulk Hogan the me yeah
I'm nan ring out as how he's on racist
not evil Hulk on my back when it was
okay like him um I don't know if I've
heard the right audio for that because
there was like here's the audio and I
listened to it I'm like it are you sure
this is the reason he was kicked out I'm
I've heard the wrong one cuz I'm like
hey wait I only read the transcript I
was like whoo that was it okay maybe
something else that yeah because what I
heard I'm like I told it was very
strange because there's wrong I was
throwing up all of this racist shit in
the Nappers like you know it gets up a
little racist this is like a that's not
like every night okay alright I don't
know like I just read the transcript
honestly I don't care cuz I even fold
poke okay than years so I'm like that
tumblr can argue that I don't care you
know it's not I don't even follow us
that's um oh is it but but I did you
like you say I did that summit just guys
are like oh that's like kind of the last
big wrestler who like what I do Andre
the Giant sergeant slaughter and so um
yeah now we're seeing sergeant slaughter
at conventions
heyo just pretty cool um like I know who
the rock is and some of the big ones but
I just a following but I know it seemed
like a good satire of like wrestling ya
know we'd like the i-beam that we know
Tyler Bryan Hinds here so yeah tell us
if they're doing it right because I
wouldn't be able to tell you I was a
very bare bones basic yeah I like that I
like the Oh whole show yeah psycho
villain you know drawing all the sodas
yeah like getting the audience to hate
you so Steven was the obvious villain
but I I know I I don't have much
commentary on it cuz I'm just like I
don't I haven't watched wrestling since
1989 yeah I mean oh we could also talk
about I mean how like you know it here's
this outlet for them to go and just sort
of you know be themselves and be
aggressive and stuff but it's not I'm
really hurting so I hurl
I love the hypocrisy of pearls like this
circus of violence and I'm like wait a
second that's a description of the whole
shit yeah okay what the who the hell are
you ladies going around destroying these
giant bugs in whatever and then just
taking them life force or whatever then
please kill the universe's creatures
great and small for the common good
you're just fake fighting in a circus of
violence wait what but they came around
to us okay I really like when they will
I realize him typing right now you know
yeah this is why they're doing it's like
we haven't gotten there yet so I know it
um but just just at the moment it's when
she goes off like that I'm like yeah um
hello the wait garnet gets knocked out
as a hitter injured um and I love the
minimalist animation on her I mean she
just barely needs to move but her design
and her voice is just so strong at this
date man well it doesn't eat I love
Stevens impression of garden where he
takes is like jew-fro hairs yeah pushes
it over and does the British accent um
that was pretty funny I hate I totally
ruined this show for him now because I
said that Stephen looks like a chubby
little Steve Guttenberg and about 20
seconds later Doug just goes god dammit
now I can't unsee it now that's all I
can see I just see a like talking that
Johnny number five uh you know I didn't
even tell the right
Oh Oh see I go if you mentioned
Gutenberg I automatically go Mahoney
yeah police academy I die I make shorts
I think short-circuited with him with
that cup of coffee turning like he's at
folders commercial I got it I got it
just that weird scene before he does the
job we such fucking 18 Stooges yeah I
though ah police academy short circuit
we know are good for damnit most
important most are audience from how are
they talking about
he was our Lady gaga oh no Lady Gaga's
Lady Gaga album where I think about oh
no he would know yeah he was he was more
such art Adams Nelly I'm saying out loud
trying to that I'm trying to think if we
have a David Hasselhoff maybe he was he
he was more he was more like the
nineties Sinbad really inoffensive but
not very funny I don't know there's a
current equivalent to they said them
like they were like it was this but
there's this like here's the positive
side you just said two negative things
great intensive and not funny
oh we're looking on topic here I mean
I'm just saying like I don't hate Sinbad
I when I say inoffensive I just mean
it's not like Adam Sandler we're in a
bad Adam Sam remember you're just like I
wanted I literally want to strangle him
watch the life escape out of his eyes
in a bad Adam Sandler movie there's some
Adam Sandler movies I really like it was
like I've never watched even jingle all
the way I don't think I'm just like I
want to strangle the life out of sindh
and then same thing with Steve
Guttenberg I've never was strangle the
life out of them they're mostly
inoffensive um but weird so on track uh
but what is what is your Steve
Guttenberg what what today in 2015 do
you think is the best equivalent of
Steve Koonin
you tell us Steven universe as Tiger
millionaire ha brought it back Oh though
we're going to hell by comparing Steven
universe to Steve Guttenberg yeah what
was I
um no though actually the one thing that
I'm gonna go back to the shadows now now
the one thing that did sort of make me
be like wait a minute why I'll be
covering this that you know guess the
little tiger nose and mouth and stuff
like that at some point like he waved by
to the the gems and he has a dot and she
like cuz oh I can't inhale you're
supposed to take off it's like what
conclusion what they draw from that hey
wouldn't conclude anything right I know
it's just even being weird Stephen um I
wish I had more to say but it's way
early in the morning yeah it is about a
son literally just came up like a minute
ago yeah which is why the lighting in
here she says why his cab we're
depending on some of the sunlight from
the window and it's just like not that
it's not enough yeah oh but it was my it
was a good episode like something a huge
wrestling people so we're not the bed by
me we know the general gist of it and
you know it's funny I thought the amount
you know it's kind of fun doing it this
early in the morning cuz I feel like I'm
10 years old again watching carton right
before I go to school and even fucking
lucky charts um yeah what gives man an
egg sandwich really you could have had
lucky charm I'm trying to cut down
anyway an exaggeration that's about
nutritious now lucky charm that's where
the real value is so um yeah oh we're
gonna go get some ones purple clovers
brown balloons some lucky charms with
chocolate-covered hamburger blue
horseshoes um I'm like getting all the
colors right here
yeah no no I was gonna say I really
don't think those are right but I'll
have a point chocolate hamburger in it
so it's okay so I hope you enjoyed this
return of just email dreamers V logs
it's talking nothing about Steven
universe
I was like no racist Lucky Charms is cuz
it's all about beating the Irish it is
these damn little kids but to wasps I
might add like running around beating
this poor - leprechaun stealing his food
this is the worst Steven universe
together it's like our final return here
you know we finally come back and it's
like we barely talked about the episode
like just not wrestling fans I'm sorry
well you know what it's 6:00 in the
morning okay this is the best I can come
up with it's 6:00 hopefully we'll put
together any much more together
oh wait for an interview we're doing
that next Oh what now we're gonna talk
so um yeah well see in the next one
later